hey guys my name is Eliot I'm live at
the Samuel Leeds pops a crash course and
look who I bumped into Sam Mitchell how
are you Sam you're very well thank you
nice to meet ya yeah so Sam Mitchell
about six months ago was it February
February so February so two months ago
Wow doesn't time fly so two months ago
you poor house dude boy Loretta hi
yes correct yeah okay so just briefly
just give me your sort of how did you
come across spoiler right now I just
come across some your leads and how did
you get onto being our cherry pick
member okay so I've come across Samuel
Leeds I bought his book on Amazon okay
I'm ready to book my low-rent hi and
really got quite inspired start to
follow him on YouTube found out about
his cherry pick membership and and I
qualified for that I'm entered into that
and then yeah I found her on our on a
Wednesday morning a property come up
that was offered towards me an HMO and
Liverpool and it looked really good a
little bit of research myself and I
spoke to you wrong you up and said I'm
really interested in that brilliant good
stuff good stuff okay so on the you
solder to top it lists how how long what
was the timeframe between you so I'm not
to be choked at member to you actually
buying you your house to us how long how
many emails just away
I'm email sort went out before you saw
one saw one that you liked what was is
the first email our first email Wow we
cannot become a cherubic member well the
first Wednesday
yeah the email come out about it was
about half past nine in the morning
something like that maybe like that and
there was someone there this one
particularly suits me suit my needs and
yeah I've researched a little bit myself
a little bit unsure I've done a bit of
research myself Victorian and now also
to mold it over a little bit and I
thought this this really suits me I'm
gonna go for it Wow brilliant brilliant
okay so just I don't even remember back
to February but what was the process so
we mailed it out yeah you got in touch
yeah what was the process from you
getting in touch to after you take after
you paid the fee what was the what's the
process
a process of voice obviously you ask me
questions a few things about me and all
that not set your in obviously I'd send
you an a proof of my wife finances of
that I can afford the property and then
I'm basically I'm genuine your interest
in the property
yeah that was the process right good
stuff good stuff so in the beginning
we'd have sent you over at homes
conditions we've got so I got the read
for your turn the condition yeah you
sent over thats always a little bit
while ago so so I remember yeah I read
before your terms and conditions and and
it's in you described a little bit more
in depth about the properties we're
about what was all about before the
plate money it's quite a little bit more
about what it's all about the property
yeah how it sort how old walls of it and
okay when you paid the fee yeah for the
house the introductory food yeah you
hadn't seen pictures of the house at all
yes in addresses you knew it's in
Liverpool yeah but you didn't know where
it was what it looked like what it was
at all did you know how did you even be
honest how did you feel about sending
over money to it you know to us for an
introductory fee on a property that
you've never seen how did you feel be
honest how did you feel I feel to be on
I don't see I'm a bit nervous and all
that but my god I've got an outline of
what it what the property was all about
from yourselves yeah so we're roughly
where abouts it was so god dude I've
done a little bit of research for an HMI
on that area it felt really good I felt
confident with the property my cell
phone technology you know I would have
been nervous it is good but I've been
I've been following Samuel Leeds I've
got a lot of confidence in how he worked
so he's ideas of my oh geez how he
performs no he's quite direct and
confident in what he does that's how I
sort of try myself in life anyway you
know I was happy Ian okay good stuff so
I do remember it vaguely on the
Wednesday we sent the email out yeah it
was about lunchtime just have to
lunchtime you rang me nod you rang me
and he said hi Elliott is the one in
Liverpool still available yeah and I
said hi Sam
I believe it is still available we have
offered it someone but for one reason or
they can't Bank cut down they're not
proceeded a ball that's right
what what did I get do they give you a
good description of the property if you
describe the whole property to me over
the phone nd Tommy exactly look like
what would it want ready and now you
give me an indication of whereabouts it
was because I wanted me to know that so
I'm good a little bit a research law
saying yeah
so he paid the fee boom in the bank
accounts I then sent put you over in
touch with the the Samuel Leeds partner
they then put you in touch the estate
agent you sent all your documents across
have you viewed the property yet in
Liverpool have you been see it my young
Ben C yet and like I haven't been to see
it I've sent out as an agent I managed
an agent to go around have a look at it
and an independent one and who might
just go with and he's able to look at it
and run the RPG specialise in H and I
was in the area he's got 84 Wow okay
it's not good oh very good he sends
someone to view the property for you
they report about saying it's a good
property could good house good area yeah
good stuff okay brilliant
so we've guards to the PHA I've no
confidence in the fame is obviously my
concerns was look what happens if this
just doesn't work out the property yeah
I know the seller decides to put it out
the mortgage
work out for me and and you did say that
you know the although the was it up not
refund law you will pass over and find
me another property that is so which
give me confidence because I want a
property I just want to make sure my
money is in a property not just Wow good
stuff great stuff okay so so how far are
you off completion on this property do
you know we've sort of metal the
criterias for the mortgage because on
first to an HMO so that's a lot of
things to go through that the mortgage
provider wanted from me and from the
property and it should be about a week
or so away from exchange contracts a
week week maybe two Wow brilliant
brilliant that's good okay so when you
exchange contracts at the weeks what's
the plan what you're gonna do with the
house the plan is I mean yeah it's
already tented so there isn't a lot
players to do I find it to update it
make sure it's all a little bit more
updated are over the course of this year
it's a little bit dated this and things
are all of the fire regulations I'll
make sure I sold met with that aren't
the reason why I went for his HMO it's
pretty much all running up and running
ready to rock and roll it's been nice
fire I return on my investment what I
sort of our island and that's what's all
about and I'm happy
good good good good okay great
so when she completes in a couple weeks
and it's all it's all going really well
and you've obviously you've already got
your tenants in place yeah would you
mind if we sort of had a bit of a catch
up and see where you're at and see where
he's going yeah I'd love to give me a
bit of a catch and plan and obviously go
there when I'll pick up the keys and
oh yeah be quite what happened good I'd
be really really good
just quickly before let you go back to
the to the to the course what would you
say to someone who's probably thinking
they've got you know the good money to
invest there's two routes finger down
that and go find houses themself or that
you know they can pay you know a
sourcing company someone who's a little
bit skeptical is probably one you know
what if it doesn't work what if he
doesn't go through you know what what if
what if what if what would you say to
someone who's you know maybe not as
Tanya's well bars Della Valle inspector
and gives you all the confidence in the
world tried to go because they've sought
out prods they take all the stress
outsourcing bombings trying to sort out
propping yourself as I did but you'd
always have in the back of the mind is
this gonna worry is this not why but
you've got people that do this for a
living who sorted day-in day-out look
for the best deals and their hands
and they're still on hand now and I'm
going through the whole process and
knodell if I'm wrong earlier I've got no
doubt my mind after all the probably
haven't got any problems running shoes
on I'll bring him up but I know he
helped me out so well that must be
really whatever their whatever the
source some fears gene ha ha thanks Sam
look it's been a pleasure it's nice to
meet you really nice to me nice put a
face to the to the to the voice on the
periphery definitely and then I'd love
to catch up you soon all right
I've been Elliot thank you for watching
I'll better head back into Sam's crash
course but see you soon